hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on four undergone
apologies for the voice I had just
spoken up but I just wanted to go over
this one really quick video that came
out or this thing actually came out I
think a couple days ago but I never got
the chance to actually cover it it is
the title update for March 12 of 2020
its title update 2.18 it's pretty much
the basically the patch for the event
has nothing to do with the event it's
just a patch that came out with the
event and this has the breach
improvements and a lot of other things
so as I was like the people do and tries
to discover if you're new now let's get
into today's video as pretty much we're
just gonna run by and look at all this
stuff I'm going to be skipping this
entire part here because this is
literally the breach 2.0 if you remember
way back when we had the testing grounds
and breach 2.0 got released that's
pretty much what this is so I will leave
an i a live a video in the I on the top
right if you want to listen to what all
those breach changes are but I'm just
gonna be skipping that for the sake of
the video next up we have some fighter
improvements it's as increased all
fighters vulnerability to guard break on
heavy opponent openers from 4 to 4 33
milliseconds the average was 400 all
fighters now have a 600 Vollmer ability
to GB on their out of stamina heavies
from 600 on most of the cast with some
exceptions this change across the whole
cast name substantially reduce instances
where the attackers perform a heavy
feint into GB and then the opponent
bounces off trying to parry the attack
on the first possible frame letting go
of their heavy essentially winning the
exchange by falling for the attackers
mix-ups I'm totally cool with that too
many times of that has happened and
especially players at a lower level that
don't understand that really the think
concept they kind of just swing whenever
they want those are the people that
really [ __ ] with you with that to
encourage attacking and outnumbered
scenarios we have lowered the GB
vulnerability of the whole cast chained
attacks that the external opponents will
have a much harder time landing
guaranteed jeebies in between here is a
text this is also helped with no live
finishers who can opt to throw out heavy
finishers to beat out guard break
attempts this this also affects moves
like multi hit zone attacks and
dedicated post parry special moves
there's always back dodge movement
standardization the following heroes had
their back
dodging movements slightly adjusted they
will now still move the same distance
overall but move slightly less back in
the beginning of their dodge and
slightly more during the end it's a
Centurion conquer BP Highlander heat so
carry Musha shaman Shaolin shinobi
Valkyrie warden and warlord this is to
avoid a lot of those heavy fame GB mix
especially with the light added in the
very beginning by back dodging so that's
really the main reason why reflux heroes
also got a quick GB comfort reflux guard
heroes cannot perform quick guard break
from a fainted attack even if they
perform a stance change during the faint
so pretty nice to that there's also been
fated heavy attack improvements we've
adjusted several heroes to ensure they
have more consistently land guard break
some chained heavies these are as
follows
we're gladiator they normalize the knock
back of light attacks to standard
distance heavy finishers now move 0.25
meters forward during the setup and be
heavy finisher faints and now move point
to 5 meters forward for Highlander the
knock back distance of his opener lights
was reduced by 20% the defensive stance
heavy finisher now moves point 5 forward
during the startup and that defensive
stance heavy finisher faints also 0.5
meters forward for lava ringer they now
move one meter forward during the
startup and the chain heavy faints now
2.25 more with the knock back distance
from the opener light attack a change
light attack and change of reduced by
50% for Kent say he's got one small buff
and that's just the normalized knock
back of open or light attacks to
standard distance or no bushi the knock
back distance from opener lights reduced
by 50%
heavy finishers movement from distance
normalized to 2.7 5 meters this was
different for each and for Shaolin it's
the knock back distance from light
openers reduced by 20% with the chain
light being 30 shoe go Kia's heavy
openers now move point 5 forward more
and then warden has adjusted knock back
distance from light openers by 20% with
the side heavy feint being point 7 5
meters forward and then we also have
some fighter adjustments for just
general stuff that had to do with a lot
of distancing with moves and attacks
this has to do with his general
improvements warden can no longer
immediately perform shoulder bash after
a throw orna can also also has his
reduced top heavy finisher to a thousand
milliseconds this used to be 1100 so a
little bit quicker
reduce shoulder bash cost to 12 stamina
that from 20 and increased forward throw
a wall splat window to 200 milliseconds
into the throw this was for 500 for
warlord they adjusted the crashing
charge on an out of stamina opponent
into a wall which will always unbalance
the opponent after applying this done
this will this see this used to only
happen during the crash in charge and
then there's also a small metal bug fix
for world load throwing out and out of
stamina opponent front or sideways into
a nearby obstacle can now decide to
apply the stun and stamina damage and
said they can unbalance the opponent by
not holding the guard break input during
the throw some of the maps especially
during some of the breach maps also got
some changes for hollowed Bastion they
moved the defender in pikemen spawn
locations behind the giant sword and
jayam and the shield monument at a new
stealth path to connect the healing zone
in the commander platform at a high wall
structure around the ballista and placed
a rune stone monolith at the base of the
stairs leading up to the commander
Citadel gate added a new ramp to capture
his own aide for defenders and added
railings on top of the ladder leading
into capture zone see temple garden had
bridges Lee air has bridges leading into
capture zone see have been modified to
now have railings and a capture zone see
has been reared so that the giant tree
roots extend to the extremities of the
zone
hence players will no longer be able to
run behind them for shard that just
added spikes on capture zone a so these
are interface they greatly reduced the
battle past pop-up skip holding time so
thank [ __ ] for that and for
customization they adjusted the player
expression of the male Raider to make
outfits look better the rest of this
article has to do with bug fixes and
they're very very minor things but of
course if you do want to read those for
yourself I'll leave a link to this down
at the description yeah let me know what
you guys think about this patch in the
comments plot this is overall a pretty
good patch this isn't anything
groundbreaking like the art of battle it
would be you know the art of combat
system update that we had for testing
grounds but a patches of patch and while
this doesn't affect many of the
characters that I play I still think
this is a cool patch nonetheless so let
me know what you guys think about this
stuff in the comments below as always
like the V if you do enjoy a subscriber
if I knew a cover the informational site
a foreigner that being the balance
changes to here updates the patch notes
and the leaks if ever gets a day with
everything happening
in the world of honor and never miss out
on an update that was described the
channel
I gots take care of girls today thank
you for watching the video peace out
you